so let's just say you're trying to build
a business okay and you have some money
you're in a good industry you have some
skills yourself you know you have a good
idea you feel good about the marketplace
what is the most important asset to you
to help you scale your business to a
whole different level most people will
say money I'm here to tell you it's
social capital and it's talented leaders
talented leaders just like in a world of
sports an organization that continuously
ones is because there are leaders in the
locker room in the world of business is
the same exact thing but there are many
organizations that know how to attract
talent but they don't know how to keep
that talented leader today I'm going to
talk about 17 different ways to lose
talented leaders in your organization
let's start off with point number one
point number one is when you when you
get that talented leader you you give
you box them in this job description
that they have to live in no you need to
only be doing this you need to only be
doing that one of the things I do when I
bring on board and executive we just
brought somebody else on board recently
and I was sitting down in the interview
with him and he was very timid I said
why are you so timid he says uh he says
how often are you here I said what do
you mean he says well look I follow you
and I saw your stuff and you're only
here once a quarter right to see their
number so what do you mean by that says
you don't live in Dallas you live in
California I had no idea was going to
interview with you today
I said no I'm here I live in Dallas I
live here
he says really I said yeah he says half
when you come to work I said every day
why are you asked I said every single
day I'm at work you're at work every
single I said yes this how's it possible
I said unless if I'm out of town like I
just got back from Hawaii this past week
I was in Hawaii negotiating with some
carriers and had a good time out there
unless unless if I'm in out of town I'm
in town running the business in Dallas
and he couldn't believe it and I said
why is your reaction this way says
because the last couple companies I've
worked at they we're doing you know not
as much as you guys but they're still
doing good and I never saw to see you at
the office but to come and get the
checks or to come and do what he had to
do everyone some I said no we're an
active actively involved company but I
said this time I said listen one of the
reasons why I'm bringing you on board is
because you've experienced what
to be dealing with all these different
responsibilities that you you have an
incredible resume finances etc etc I'm
bringing you on board is because I want
you to give us ideas I want you to come
and tell us have you guys thought about
doing this with finances I think that's
not about doing that what fine I said
this is your job description that you
have because we have to give you a title
but I just want you to know if we get
about the title for a moment if you have
things that you think we can do better I
want you to come to me if you feel that
there's a better positioning with you I
want you to give your feedback because I
want to hear from you on why you think I
want to hear it but I don't want you to
think you're in a box and he said no
one's ever told that to me so what
happens I think I thought about doing
this have you guys we already have value
from bringing somebody like that on
board I think too many times when you
bring the talented leader who's already
coming with a strong background where
maybe they've had some success or
there's somebody that's continuously
doing things and they want to find your
home because most of the time talented
leaders don't like to change and go from
one place to another place to another
place to another place they'd like to
find a home and build then you saw Kobe
State with a team for 20 years they'd
like to build an organization themselves
is what they want to do is because it's
bigger than them but you can't box a
talented leader in one little place and
saying this is all you can do what else
do you think we could be doing here one
of the things about earlier behind the
camera Elias always got great ideas I
tell Elliot Elliot tell me what you
think we can be doing for great ideas
and my Russian man behind the camera
Ilya I've got to give you some credit to
your for give you some love on this when
he's teaching me some more Russian as
we're doing this so number one don't box
your people with a job description next
thing expecting too much too soon when
you bring a talent to leader on board I
think it takes about 30 60 90 days for
them to kind of scope things out for
them to kind of see where they fit for
them to kind of see what things they
have to do so for me it's more look
within the first 30 60 90 days here's
what I'm expecting from you I'm
expecting for you to learn our system
learn our language learn our culture
learn what we got going on and I want to
hear you come back to me with some
reporting on areas that you think we can
improve in this and proving that
improving this and my only expectation
from you is right now to figure out ways
to make this better for you grab ways
for this to be a stronger organization
in this specific department are you
current
working with but also at the same time I
need you to be giving me feedback and I
need you to come here and tell us what
things we can do better and on top of
that if throughout the process you have
any questions every single day whatever
questions you have don't worry about it
keep asking questions when we get to
will answer questions for you
but we want you to find out more about
the internal side of the organization
here ok great that's the expectation for
the first 30 60 90 days then the
expectation goes higher on what we want
to do but there's seasons for
expectation to be higher and lower we
had a meeting this morning with my staff
and it wasn't the most motivational type
of a meeting this morning with the
leaders we sat down we had a very direct
conversation for certain areas at the
Home Office that I expect to improve and
it was a high expectation but everybody
is a veteran who would have known that
this conversation was coming up now the
complete next point point number three
is to lose talented leaders is expecting
too little the talented leaders are not
trying to do something just because I
want to get a salary they can go work
anywhere they want to do something
because it's more it's pushing the
envelope more it's doing something
that's never been done before it's doing
something that's gonna make an impact
it's seeing somebody that's in it with
them doing what they want to expect more
they're almost surprised if they're not
being called out
they're almost surprised if there's not
a high expectation of a performance we
want to put up or beat our prior best
numbers or do something we've never done
before we want to build the biggest most
you know biggest largest financial
marketing we want to build the biggest
realistic we want to build the biggest
winnable the best technology want to
build the best customer service there's
got to be an expectation so sometimes
you know talented leaders when the
expectation is too low so so far we have
boxing somebody in the description
expecting too much too early expecting
too little the next one is breaking your
promises if you don't keep your promises
when you're having some talented leaders
party organization eventually they see
it at see that as a trend and they don't
necessarily take you serious as some of
the things you're saying we're going to
do as the organization is real so
breaking promises very simple next one
is promoting the wrong people up so when
you promote and build up the wrong
people they see that
and they read between the lines and it
becomes very obvious now what are the
wrong people now somebody may watch this
and somebody may say that's why I'm
leaving the company because that's
exactly what they did at my company
before you say that ask yourself are you
just a talented person that's not
willing to improve are you a talented
leader because maybe somebody got the
promotion over you because you're just
the talent that's not willing to lead
you got to know that one and maybe
you're just a teller maybe you're not
willing to lead yourself because the
talented leaders are a different story
what happened here with the folks in
business but when you when you give
credit to the person that's not setting
the best example that's not willing to
work hard that's not but because it's
just somebody you want to give that to
and they kind of sit in a sense that and
say this so no matter what I do I'm not
gonna get the best credit here in the
company I just don't like what they're
going the direction they're going
because they're gonna have favorites
with people that are doing less you're
gonna lose talented leaders eventually
within your business the next one is
this failure to get rid of or break ties
with people that deserve to get fired if
someone doesn't fit in a culture or an
organization and you don't fire them
early you will have a problem with the
talented leaders for me if I have
somebody that comes on board then we
give everybody a shot and let's you say
somebody comes on board and we'll all of
a sudden see there's just not a fit here
for them to work with us we will very
quickly fire that person and move on not
only for our sake but more importantly
for their sake as well because it's just
time to move on if you're not somebody
that fitting the mold and fitting the
vision that we have you're just not a
fit and you shouldn't be afraid of doing
that I think that's something that
people have a hesitation with I think
the first person that I was hiring as an
assistant I don't know how many of them
I went through but you don't need to be
very hesitant when you're doing that
you're looking for leaders on people
that you're hiring at all levels so you
need to be able to get rid of some
people that don't fit them all on what
you're building next thing failure to
give credit where credit is due somebody
did something and they're too talented
leader and they were the reason why this
technology came out give them the credit
if there were a reason why a certain
initiative was very successful give them
the credit if there was a reason why
something incredibly good
the company gives them to credit as
quickly as possible when that takes
place because sometimes that's all they
want hey man I did that that's right you
did do that we're proud of you great job
with the initiative phenomenal job we
didn't do it you came up with that and
because that a company's experiencing
some success because the idea they came
up with phenomenal job and instead of
wanting to take that credit for yourself
because talented leaders sometimes it's
not just about the dollar amount it's
about the credit it's about the
contribution they're making to the
organization as well next one next one
is not showing you genuinely care for
them these are human beings at the end
of the day there's got to be a care for
people that you're building with in
business not everyone's gonna be your
best friend in the world not everyone's
going to become like a brother of yours
or somebody that's like a family or
sister of yours but people are human
beings and when you're building a team
people want to know that you care about
the people as well point number nine
never admitting you're wrong if you're
wrong
just come out and say I was wrong I made
a mistake this was my fault this was my
bad I'm gonna get better
I apologize let's move on and everybody
says hey thank you for doing that while
he's the bigger man this is somebody I
wanted to follow let's go ahead and move
on and get to the next step in that
small little conversation of I made a
mistake I was wrong I apologize saves so
much drama from what from losing the
talented leaders that can help your
organization go to the next level next
one point number 10 you not being
predictable talented leaders want to
work with other talented leaders that
are very predictable at the time they
show up to work at what they do on a
daily basis their habits their work
habits their attitude their personality
their high/low their they the way their
were everything every single thing
they're watching for your predictability
on your delivery because a talented
leader generally has those things and
they're not necessarily worried if you
know more a lot of times people I got a
call some from the other day from
somebody that I'm advising and he runs a
very successful company I think they
just rate thirty thirty five million
dollars they just recently raised and he
gave me a call and he says look man some
strange things are happening I said like
what he says we're starting to hire some
engineers that are 10 times better than
me what do I do about that you know I
don't really know how to handle these
people that are 10 times better than me
I said look those people are not looking
for you to have all the answers they're
not looking for you to know everything I
mean Phil Jackson doesn't coach Jordan
and Kobe because he's better at playing
the game than they are they just want to
know that you're a leader and you're in
it with them so they're coming to work
with you for different reasons they're
not expecting and have all the answers
but they want to make sure you're a
predictable leader that's willing to
show up every single day to build this
monstrosity that you guys want to build
as long as you do that you have their
respect he says you know what I'm so
glad I talked to I never thought about
it that way anyone back about his
business I make two book recommendations
to man he's off to the races
so part number tenants you not being
predictable point number eleven not
sending a great personal example a
little bit of character issues you know
this month's book of the month that we
read here it has to do with ethics it
has to do with doing the right things
and it's a constant reminder that when
you're a leader everybody else is
watching your example I know this is a
boring subject but everybody as a CEO as
an entrepreneur who are working with you
or for you they are watching your habits
on what you're doing they're watching
you more closely than you think they are
they're watching every single move
you're making and character issues
typically are not hard to see and find
and generally you may lose a talented
person or talent the leader and you
never know why years later you realize
it was the character that lost that
talented leader you have very important
to straight strong in that area number
12 no vision you don't have a vision of
where you're going there's not a vision
with the next step is there's not a
vision of where the company is going
towards so it's just a we're just
building a company we're just doing this
there's not something bigger than that
that they're going after with you and
everyone knows when a vision is real
when it's toughed about hundreds of
times if somebody makes up a vision they
generally only say for about a month or
two and then never comes up again if
somebody truly has a vision they bleed
it all the time and they're talking
about it all the time you got to have a
clear vision of where you're going with
your organization to maintain those
people who are also big thinking
talented leaders themselves point number
thirteen not allowing them to make
mistakes you know if the environment of
a workplace is like
walking on eggshells oh my gosh that is
a very annoying environment to be in
I'm all for mistakes I'm all for
mistakes I don't have any problem with
mistakes I have problems with old
mistakes I don't have a problem with new
mistakes new mistakes to me are we tried
something that didn't happen it's
totally fine I guess it didn't work
let's move on old mistakes to me are we
already tried this three other times and
it didn't work and why are we doing it
again okay but if it's a new mistake
completely fine Pat I would think about
if we did this would be good for the
company I thought thought thought
thought thought and I got the proven and
they asked for this so we tried and you
said this and then but it didn't work
out no problem as long as we're getting
to your program we're looking it's good
to go okay perfect here's what it costs
okay they don't work what are we doing
next now obviously there's a component
of it they you got to prove the
financials when you're doing that but I
don't necessarily have a problem with
new mistakes I have a very big problem
with old mistakes so you lose talented
leaders when you don't allow them to be
wrong and make the mistakes that they're
making in business number fourteen not
being a hands-on unaware of what's going
on on a daily basis I'll explain to what
I mean let's just say you have Joey here
who's the extremely talented leader and
could be somebody long-term for your
business for your organization right but
Joey is working with Bobby okay and
Bobby is somebody that's sloppy he shows
up every once in a while he's a very
demanding boss who doesn't do it himself
and he's not and work every single day
but he wants to tell everybody what to
do but Bobby is not telling you about
Joey so you don't know that Joey's
really the one that's making Bobby look
good Bobby's not gonna tell you I'm
doing good because of Joey the only way
you're gonna find out that Joey is doing
it over Bobby is if you're a hands-on
leader and you go in there shaking hands
and you talk to everybody all you need
to do is go visit a visitor site or is
it an office visit an organization and
you'll generally see everybody in the
office is talking about Joey then you
find out maybe it's Joey then people
will generally tell you about Bobby when
you talk about everybody will find out
Joey so if you wouldn't have gone in
there spend the time you would have
never found out who the real leaders
which is Joey and you know this happens
to me all the time when I go visit and
do site visits I realize man that's the
guy right there that runs this office
look at what they got going on these go
well I never
do you I never knew her well it's good
then I know what I'm dealing with myself
because the value of a great
organization is purely based on the
value of the talented leaders may you as
a leader of the organization can retain
and maintain and tell them instead of
losing to another competitor next one
point over 15 measuring hours instead of
results we have a place here where you
clock in with your fingers finger
printing we have that we've had that all
these years so you come in you clock a
bunch of finger prints and if you ask me
how many times we've had this for five
years now if you ask me how many times
I've actually seen a report of what time
people sign in from five years ago till
today the answer is this many times I
have no idea I've never seen it I've
never said well listen I can tell you
you've come here at 9:07 at 9:03 and
9:02 at 909 and at 8:59 four out of five
there's your six seven minutes I've
never had that coverage anybody that's
I've never had a conversation with them
I've just never had a conversation with
them why I've had conversation with you
told me this is the deadline how come to
sudden get done you told me this is what
you told me this it was going to be
April first and it's not done yet why
are we doing this you give you a
commitment that this is we're gonna have
what happened here I'm more concerned
about that than I'm concerned about ours
that's what I'm concerned about and so
talented leader they're driving they're
working they're constantly building
their initiative you know they generally
don't like to be micromanage by somebody
they want to show you what they got
going on they don't mind being held
accountable every once they don't might
be in held accountable at all they have
no problem with that based on the
results they're making not based on the
hours they're putting again based on the
results if I'm creating these results
and you want to hold me accountable to
these results and they're not at the
level you expect I understand that but
not the hours okay you want these result
cuz this is what they really could do
next no clear direction you have a
talented leader they want you to give
them direction I want you to first do
this then do this then do this we want
the company to be doing this this this
I'd like to see the company going this
direction then this then this and I see
you helping us with this perfect guy
what's most important and important
priority right now boom boom boom I set
that some of our leaders and I said your
focus is this here's what we need from
you your focus is that we need this from
your focus
can you help me a little bit more under
some what you want from me on this end
if I hit this where you need to do this
what if I do this then you do this okay
great perfect what do you think that's
the part with any clear direction is
what they need the more clarity there is
for everybody
everyone's gonna boom boom boom hitting
their targets from point number 17 point
number 17 euros talented leaders if
they're not being challenged if they're
not being challenged very few people
complain about a direct superior most
people will tell you I don't like the
person I'm working with most people
won't tell you about it direct Sabine
complain about them but if you go deep
end find out when you're working with
people you realize man these people are
not being challenged this person could
be a very major player in the company
but he's not being challenged she's not
being challenged they're not being
challenged why are they not being
challenged generally a person who's not
challenged and another person is because
this person is not fully in so when
you're not fully in yourself you don't
expect more from other people because
you don't expect more from yourself but
a leader himself who's all-in it's very
easy to expect more from other people so
my challenge to you that you're watching
this is to realize that the value of
your business the value of your
organization can go to the roof if you
if you yourself as the CEO of the
business that you're running could get
better at attracting leaders and at
maintaining and retaining talented
leaders that's my message to you and if
you haven't subscribed to this channel
please do so by clicking here and if you
haven't gone on the website go visit
Patrick mid david.com thanks for
watching take care bye
you